aquí lo importante es diferenciar las
dos cosas la protesta social y lo otro
que es cómo se enquistan algunas
organizaciones criminales y generan
actos vandálicos que pues son reprimidos
por la fuerza pública bajo un estricto
protección de derechos humanos hay que
recordar que colombia ha avanzado mucho
en capacitar a su fuerza pública en
derechos humanos
y pues también entender que así como lo
muestran las imágenes pues hay algunas
organizaciones criminales que aprovechan
dicen que están haciendo protestas pero
lo que están haciendo es atacar a la
fuerza pública hasta el punto de que
tratan de mente de quemar a 11 policías
aquí al sur de bogotá 11 policías que
tienen hijos que tienen esposa que tiene
miedo que no quieren ya ni salir de sus
casas y no entienden porque sé que se
les trata de agredir y porque se les
trata de maltratar ahora bien si hay
persona social ha existido seguramente
actos vandálicos o actos no acordes a la
ley por parte de la policía pues
nosotros somos una democracia y sabrá la
sabrá la justicia castigar a aquellos
que no han cumplido los protocolos de
derechos humanos pero aquí lo que
tenemos es que avanzar por una parte en
el diálogo y rechazar completamente a
los van al vandalismo terrorista que
quiere infiltrar la protesta y quiere
generar miedo y caos en colombia'
representante pero si la policía como
usted bien lo dice tiene miedo de salir
a las calles por todos estos actos en su
contra quien defiende el pueblo
es que ese es un tema muy complejo
porque mire usted yo le estoy hablando
de lo que mis propios las personas que
cuidan de mí porque pues he tenido
varias amenazas por parte de las de ln
de las disidencias trataron de hacerme
un atentado pero pero ellos mismos me
dicen mire nosotros queremos volver a
nuestras casas nosotros no salimos a una
marcha para agredir a alguien pero lo
que uno ve sistemáticamente es que hay
organizaciones criminales que andan
haciendo y trataron de hecho de tomarse
el congreso y andan haciendo desórdenes
y a esas organizaciones criminales yo le
he hecho un llamado a la ciudadanía para
que empecemos nosotros como ciudadanos a
expulsarlos y expulsarlos por una parte
de la marcha pacífica y por otra parte
expulsarlos de nuestro propio entorno a
fin de que esas personas sean
individualizadas capturadas y judicial
izadas y se respete por una parte la
protesta social pero también se respete
a la fuerza pública porque antes de
portar un uniforme son seres humanos y
por eso
nosotros hemos hecho el llamado a
protegerlos